welcome to Hannity busy night tonight
Democrats they are anxious is very night
very anxious Jerry Nadler all of a
sudden is beginning to sweat the
cowardly shift well he's looking even
more shifty than he usually is by the
way he was the only guy caught on tape
actually colluding with Russians Oh tell
me what you have we got naked pictures
about butt-naked pick that up Tom does
vitomir know so on tape that idiot he
thought he was getting Intel to impact
our elections why don't we look
investigate that guy anyway I digress
the infighting between Pelosi her
radical base is getting worse every
single day and the fringe far-left
candidates running to be President are
more than scary they're also less than
inspiring and their ideas are chilling
but the Democratic Party tonight as we
come on the air there are in shambles
and for good reason the multi-year
Russia collusion hoax was a failure
Trump winning happened they can't accept
truth and reality four investigations
have exonerated the president and by the
way look at his presidency a huge
success thank goodness thank God the
economy is booming The Forgotten men and
women nearly 7 million Americans off of
food stamps as many off of out of
poverty and we have the lowest
unemployment the best employment
situation since 1969 and yes people left
behind every demographic are doing
better setting record low unemployment
numbers in this country that is great
news but for the Democrats oh they're
playing I guess whatever they always do
games they're not doing anything to help
the American people they don't have any
agenda that's going to solve our problem
it's a card that they keep playing over
and over again Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia
maybe if we investigate a hundred times
we'll get the conclusion we want and
that doesn't work that way because in
their desperate effort to keep their
Russia collusion hoax that conspiracy
theories alive for as long as possible
well chairman Jerry Nadler the Judiciary
Committee and Intel chair that's
frightening Adam the Cowardly ship
they're forcing Bob Muller to testify in
public on Capitol Hill and he kind of
said he didn't want to do it he's only
going to stick to the report we'll see
next Wednesday I don't
this is gonna work out the way they
think matter of fact I'm almost certain
according to the AP Democrats are now
beginning to listen to Hannity they're
worried about next wednesday's hearing
I'm excited about it they should be
robert muller has long said that the
report will speak for itself no
collusion no conspiracy zero charges for
obstruction of justice that was decided
as it should be special counsel law if
they'd actually read it by the Attorney
General the Deputy Attorney General on
the office of legal counsel those
questions have all been thoroughly
answered in the exhaustive frankly
political poorly written horribly you
know law base four hundred forty eight
page report meanwhile Republicans should
focus on the litany of what are
unanswered questions that we have
previewed on this program last night
we're going to do for a full hour
tomorrow night the political bias the
prosecutorial misconduct politics
conflict of interest so many other
crucial topics will finally get the
attention they deserve that's going to
come from the Republicans on that
committee and it's coming and this comes
as the Democrats frenzied calls for
impeachment they're actually gone quiet
look at this from political quote the
most prominent house advocates for
impeachment proceedings acknowledge the
pushes yeah slowed to a standstill that
means if you want to go ahead great
because that's gonna guarantee Trump's
reelection and the Republicans control
the House and Senate and we could solve
more of America's problems and help The
Forgotten men and women even more become
richer and raise the standard of living
and become energy independent where the
straits of hormuz will never matter to
us again in terms of strategic foreign
policy but that's not stopping Navajos
never-ending subpoena party look at what
he wants now he wants to now plan to
again forcibly interview a boatload of
current former administration officials
as part of what is now the fifth
official fifth official duplicate
investigation into what we already know
there was no Trump Russia collusion of
conspiracy and the cowardly shift the
guy who's on tape colluding with the
Russian guy he's conducting a separate
sixth investigation how many bites of
the Apple they
president Trump summed it up perfectly
wrote quote Democrats have asked to see
12 more people who have already spent
hours with Robert Muller spent a fortune
on lawyers in doing so how many bites of
the Apple do they get to before working
on border loopholes asylum oh and maybe
jobs and keeping America safe and secure
and prosperous and as you watch all this
you gotta wonder do they care about
anybody in the country besides
themselves and their psychotic rage and
hatred towards Trump this is beyond a
psychosis now Democrats don't care if
they've bankrupt private citizens with
legal bills not only did they testify
before mode they want them to answer the
same questions that they've given to the
House committee the Senate committee the
Muller report how many more times you're
going to fourth this is harassment
they should be caring about what is a
desperate situation at the border they
don't even care about the so-called
dreamers or daca which they claim they
used to they could have agreed to the
president's compromise they refused to
even sit and talk with them and now the
only thing Democrats seem to care about
is smearing besmirching and slandering
the president and destroying anyone and
everyone who supports him and quite
frankly this is beyond sick a great deal
maker is now in the White House he's
willing to negotiate even with you
people that hate him with both sides of
the aisle on so many important issues to
move the country forward to help let's
see the carpenters the plumbers the
electricians the nurses and everybody
else in America raise their standard of
living is that what they're focused on
no because these people on the left and
their buddies in the media mob they
can't see through the fog of their own
rage to sit and come to the table and
solve America's problems and make
America better safer place for our
children and grandchildren oh what a
novel idea instead they're still
obsessively talking about conspiracy
theories hoax and lies that they've been
peddling for over two years and a stack
of frivolous subpoenas from the washed
up lawyers in the Democratic House I'm
gonna get back to my monologue by the
way I have advice for people if you've
gone and you've cooperated and you've
answered the questions again and again
and again my advice is you may want to
say you know
I'm done fifth amendment I don't have to
say anything just an idea but what do I
know I'm only a talk-show host